[Musique]
toujours et le chef david et saute la foi
pour 3 2 pp de la bêta le texte de bob la
la lave et la soie ne lui appartiennent pas et font son alle
s'arrête si jamais tout pousse du soleil
tasse
Peut-être qu'il croyait que Sheen l'avait choisi
au vaisseau électro tu sens que l'usine consacre
le sien a été utilisé pour un album à La Spezia
puis premier numéro de monique stéréo
de crise rien ne sait si on chante les deux
les notes des dossiers médicaux
Oui
un faux puis continue fait d'elle
histoire d'amour d'israël avec des ressorts
un ménage fou pour l'instant lacéré
logiciel de sacoche de paix expulsé
les gains des oui peuvent être comparés
che la pa télécom to machine à part
bonne volonté du pilori mois 6 pétitions
denis ou moyennement choisir la partie
décibel accepter le silicone et tout
comme nous l'entendons de nombreuses nuits, c'est
prêt à sas ou votre sa et al fresco a
boum gêne notre vie quelle mer fixe c'est
en pas pieux fonder une minute qui est
Trier une équipe à domicile à la fin de la batte
mais deux syllabes ratdeux marquent phillips
puis Florence la plus saine d'entre vous
22 avec le s plus deux usines en e
nous serons historiques ce centrage elea metal
je oui la crise du chef la base de l'équipe 2
sansuini mi6 évolue et reçoit bien
ajouts de match et le 7 tous dans le temps huit
et une demi-heure presque homme machine
automatique qui causera vient mais le duce est là
une montagne de spaghettis dont on sait
iniquité les spaghettis moelleux tu es à moi
de soros et plus est omis si jamais vous passez
cent sont un pacte entre jolie della
partie iii et sila mais voir plus groupe a
mélangez vos séparations i et le pad iii d sud
qui peut le croire en sava croit crac da ma
bout
et s'il sait que le facussè l'apat cas
de l'aigle se bat pour tracer le chemin de la souris
que le destin du petitot imagine le
compression que le phénomène nation
il a réussi à augmenter la clarté des pads
frets applaudissements danube images il semble
[Musique]
et le camion bovisa g je dirais quoi d'autre
taxes à sulmona mail fin alma cooking
de nénuphars à la machine dans la vôtre
l'hydraulique des légumineuses se termine à 2600
infiltration de quelques pommes signées est
de perdu même le choix y apparaît
récompense la paix tire un bon pro deux ex
pilotes machine à pâte lisa ou la
machine en fait de l'aluminium à partir d'un placage
que je creuse la femme qui a le cancer
poignets liste de la mienne mais je mets
de l'ogre tu viens avec des bonbons et c'est mieux de
pat a dit exemple de minutes